who would you bet on in a fight Zuck or
Elon uh I'm gonna go with whoever one I
can invest with if you could switch
places one other athlete
nobody I'm blessed but I wouldn't mind
being LeBron would you rather get
tickets to Oppenheimer or Barbie what's
the what is that are they both kid
movies is Taylor Swift taking over the
world she might be who is your dream
golf foursome with one athlete one
artist and one actor artists we're gonna
grow a little baby actor we're gonna go
Leonardo Dicaprio and athlete Steph
Curry what's your wildest fan
interaction when people have the tattoos
on the body of me like that's probably
the most loved that I've ever seen
you're on the ox
[Music]
I don't know the exact songs but I could
just give you artists I'm gonna go
little baby Drake and Wayne